يعني هذه طبعا كما قلنا حاله يمكن
ليست حاله عامه يعني وانما هي عندما ولدت
هذه الاحزاب
الدينيه في عصرنا
حملت معها مثل هذه الامور من اجل ان تجذب
الاتباع والانصار اليها والا نحن انا اذكر
عندما كنا يعني في العراق
لم نكن نسمع بهذه الامور يعني ليست هي
بندا من البنود الدينيه او عندما كنا في
لبنان في بيئتنا وفي اجواءنا
لم نعش مثل هذه
الحاله التي تبنتها فيما بعد يعني احزاب
كما قلنا من اجل ان تجدر اليها الاتباع
والانصار
كلنا نحن مامرون بان يعني
نتبع
الائمه اهل البيت
الذي كان يقول امامهم علي بن ابي طالب اني
اكره لكم ان تكونوا سبابين عندما سمع
جماعه من اصحابه يسبون في عند
حرب الشام
قال لهم اني اكره لكم ان تكونوا سبابين
فلذلك هذه يعني امور
لم تكن وارده في
قواميس اهل البيت وائمه اهل البيت
ولذلك يعني العموم يجتربونها لكن يمكن ان
لابد ان يبقى اشخاص مثلا قد يحملون مثل
هذه
يعني العقليه
التي فيها لا تخلو من التعصب ومن الابتعاد
عن المبادئ الدينيه التي تدعو الى الاحسان
والى المحبه والى التسامح والى احترام
الرموز الدينيه لكل المذاهب والطوائف
والاديان